[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio a tutti Io sono Camilla
e io sono Francesca e insieme siamo le
opposite Siamo due ragazze di Mirandola
Infatti essere qui per noi è un onore
perché siamo cresciute qui e oggi vi
porteremo nel nostro mondo creativo
durante la pausa vi sono state chieste
delle parole alcune di queste Anzi sono
state tutte raccolte noi le abbiamo
sbirciate e alcune di queste ci daranno
l'ispirazione per scrivere insieme a voi
la canzone dato che anche se il format
dice Scriviamo una canzone in 15 minuti
non li abbiamo 15 minuti sono meno
Quindi abbiamo già messo giù due tre
barre che vi facciamo sentire adesso e
poi vi spieghiamo com'è tutto il
processo che ci porta poi fino al primo
ritornello perché alla fine in 15 minuti
non si scrive tantissimo Esatto quindi
siate Clementi abbiamo fatto cioè faremo
una strofa un ritornello insieme a voi e
niente quindi Possiamo cominciare io vi
volevo intanto far sentire cosa ho
buttato giù dietro le quinte Facci
sentire ok Aspetta però già fammi i
primi quattro accordi che ti vengono in
mente
[Musica]
Allora te la butto giù così magari
pensavo
al mondo come è strano il mio vecchio
Grande amore Lo saluto da lontano con la
mano come estraneo non mi guarda neanche
in faccia tengo ancora quella foto dove
hai fatto la linguaccia mi sono fermata
qua ok Beh vi piace
la scritta così velocemente
perché ho notato che nelle parole che ci
avete consegnato il Mood era comunque
spensierato felice c'era anche un
bellissimo verbo che è sorridere e
quindi ho detto dai buttiamola sul
ridere parliamo dei vecchi amori che
abbiamo avuto tutti in questa stanza
molto molto molto carino È una buona
base però adesso cosa devi fare devi
fare la Top Line cioè devi si devi fare
la Top Line ma prima spieghiamo cos'è la
Top Line Allora in pratica la Top Line
in una canzone quella cosa che avete
presente quando la radio passano la
canzone Una canzone per la prima volta
vi piace un casino e poi dopo senza
averla riascoltata fate na na na na na
na na na questa roba qua è la Top Line
che è la melodia della canzone di solito
si parte da questo non è sempre vero
cioè in realtà col tempo abbiamo
imparato che scrivere è molto più
cogliere dei dettagli nella vita
quotidiana e ci sono delle delle cose
che magari io la Cami ci scriviamo che
dicono nostre amiche mentre stiamo
bevendo qualcosa e che nessun altro
scriverebbe Cioè ci siamo solo io e lei
che ci mettiamo così a scrivere la
prossima volta che ti vedo
cioè Ok Ehm però prendiamo spunto da
tutte queste cose e magari in quel caso
partiamo dal testo Però di solito si
parte dalla melodia e io faccio la
melodia non è sempre vero eh però sui
testi faccio un po' più Esatto visto che
siamo in due io sono il paroliere e lei
è la musicista ti facciamo sentire ok
Poi poi ci giudicherete voi e ti devo
ricantare Sì sì perché sennò non capisco
e spero di ricordarmela comunque perché
delle volte mi dicono Ok vai vai
pensavo
al mondo come è strano il mio vecchio
Grande amore Lo saluto da lontano con la
mano come
non mi guarda neanche in faccia tengo
ancora quella foto dove hai fatto la
linguaccia non mi no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no
lo stesso Rada Ok amore no no no no no
no fare no no no no no no no no no no no
no no
no no no no no no
grazie grazie
io ti ho fatto sentire l'idea poi non è
che dobbiamo tenere questa cioè se non
ti piace qualcosa non va bene Hai anche
cominciato dicendo non mi all'inizio sì
non mi ci può stare che succede delle
volte che quando scriviamo usiamo il
fake english o il fake italian Cioè
mentre lei fa na na na narè dice delle
parole vere e noi per aiutarci poi le
usiamo veramente
e quindi Ok me la me la ricanti un
secondo un secondino e poi ti lascio il
pubblico
e però lui ha cambiato accordi quindi
già Ripartiamo dal Brit e nana no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no non
andare non so come sei adesso
[Musica]
e vado al mare ok E poi da qua a voi
ancora è anche ritornello
eh ok A posto Grazie mille Adesso mi
ritiro le mie stanze a scrivere
mi sono accorta che tutte le parole che
ci sono state date Oggi
le ho messe tutte raggruppate da una
parte però è un problema ragazzi No
grazie mille Se aveste risposto Sì me ne
sarei andata dal palco comunque
te la canto e poi così la impari e poi
dopo però facciamo cantare anche loro Ok
ok Vai vai che non vedevano l'ora di
farlo Ok te l'ho data inizio
al mondo come è strano il mio vecchio
grande amore all'orso saluto da lontano
con la mano come estraneo non mi guarda
neanche in faccia tengo ancora quella
foto dove hai fatto la linguaccia e non
mi giudicare se mi prendo male quando mi
vengono a dire che di me parli male non
mi screditare non so come sei adesso ma
se ritornassi indietro Io ti lascerei lo
stesso e vado al mare poi mi manca un
pezzo da fare non costa tanto la
felicità
e se mi va mi guarderò il tramonto solo
qua
[Musica]
Grazie grazie grazie
molto brava Grazie mille
molto brava solo capire perché c'era
anche fiore da mettere mi piace
tantissimo Ok allora Mi era venuta da
dire e vado al mare con 20 euro di
benzina che già questa è una frase poco
credibile con 20 euro non vai da nessuna
parte ma non importa c'è la licenza
poetica però visto che parla di stare
bene da soli
Pensavo di scrivere e vado al mare con
€20 di benzina e un fiore non costa
tanto la felicità
per me per me ci sta per me ci sta per
me ci sta per voi ci sta
Grazie Allora facciamo così
facciamo un intro che cantano loro con
noi Esatto facciamo Ok inventiamoci un
coro così potete anche battere le mani
insieme a noi
[Musica]
esatto
più alto
[Musica]
sono Timidi
bello ok pensavo
al mondo come è strano il mio vecchio
Grande amore Lo saluto da lontano con la
mano come estraneo non mi guarda neanche
in faccia tengo ancora quella foto dove
hai fatto la linguaccia e non mi
giudicare sempre prendo male quando mi
vengono a dire che di me parli male non
mi sgridializzare non so come sei adesso
ma se ritornassi indietro Io ti lascerei
lo stesso e vado al mare con 20 euro di
benzina un fiore non costa tanto la
felicità
e se mi va mi guarderò al tramonto solo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
Allora io farei qualche ringraziamento
intanto a Giovanni un applauso Giovanni
tanta pazienza e anche uno dei nostri
producer Quindi l'uomo più uno degli
uomini più pazienti al mondo e grazie
davvero per averci dato questo
opportunità Adesso vi facciamo ascoltare
il nostro ultimo singolo che è uscito
giusto ieri e si chiama Rockstar
[Musica]
oggi il tuo profumo non mi lascia in
pace che ogni stanza ma mi segue Pure
qua non capisco se mi dà fastidio se mi
piace che è cazzata Poi col tempo
passerà ma dico capisci Non so se mi va
stare qui con te o fare cazzo che mi
pare ti dico sparisci non rimani qua non
sopporto dire amore dobbiamo parlare
e quante volte Aspetterò che giorni
quante volte poi mi passerà
canterò da sola qui concerti dove il
nostro amore come quello d'arancia
che mi piace perdermi fottermi o fare
qualcosa
forse non pensare a quello che non siamo
più Baciami E stringimi forte l'acqua
per lasciarmi il segno e dopo non
guardarmi più ricco capisci Non so se mi
va festeggiare qui con te a fare il
cazzo che mi pare ti dico sparisci non
rimani qua non sopporto dire amore
dobbiamo parlare
e quante fate Aspetterò che giorni
quante volte poi mi passerà
canterò da sola qui concerti dove il
nostro amore come quello d'arancia e
quante volte Aspetterò che torni quante
volte poi mi passerà Non dirmi che non
te lo ricordi dove il nostro amore è
come quello la nostra
[Musica]
guariscino che non mi va Non ho mai
imparato a fare quello che mi pare che
se poi sparisci Sai mi mancherà perdere
il controllo Come fanno le rock
Star Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]